are you excited about uh James Webb
Space Telescope and other telescopes in
the future that increase the resolution
and the Precision of what can be
detected out there absolutely
um jwst is fantastic already I am not
planning to use it personally although I
think I'm on one or two observing
proposals actually because similar to
what we already spoke about we're
interested in the same thing we're just
kind of looking at the different sides
of the fence right I have my my old
surviving stars and I concoct these
little stories about what the earliest
galaxies may have looked like what what
the objects were that contributed you
know energy and and elements and all
these things and uh my jwst colleagues
they try to detect some of these
earliest photons from these earliest
systems to look at the energetics and
and other things you know what was there
how many these kinds of things right so
together we're trying to to explore this
first billion years this
but we do it in very complementary ways
and so I'm I'm very excited to see what
what they can come up with and how that
helps me to inform my stories better and
more comprehensively
uh what do you think is the future
of the of the field of Stellar
archeology how much can we
maybe what are the limits of our our
understanding of this first billion
years of our uterus
um well obviously lots of limitations in
the sense that I always say I have a
metal poor star for any of your
questions
because there are so many different
kinds out there
um and we still find new patterns
sometimes right and there needs to be an
explanation the question is is it
ultimately just one quirky star or is it
two or is it three right is it is it a
sample is it a population so we haven't
concluded that kind of work yet so every
metal poor star
is the kind of data point that you can
use to improve the quality of your model
of how the evolution of the early
Universe yes yes and I would say we're
we've made huge progress over the last
20 years when I joined that field it was
in its infancy and there was this
serendipitous discovery of that first
second generation star
and we have filled in the canvas a great
deal since then and this is what I have
greatly enjoyed about doing so because
there was so much Discovery potential
and it's been it's been dying down a
little bit because of all the progress
um it's gonna it's gonna it's on on the
up and coming again because there's so
many large spectroscopic surveys in the
works now that will just provide a
different level of data that we haven't
had before I'm sort of of these older
generation I have only very few
colleagues I work in small teams and I
observe every single star myself
that you know I whatever I can I do
myself I don't generally take other
people's data at least not certainly not
in the end stage and and uh you know I'm
not a big data kind of person although
we're all headed that that way I I
certainly use uh data from the Gaia
astrometric satellite for the kinematics
for example but that's personally a new
thing for me to to use sort of Big Sky
surveys
um that are available
um so it's still very sort of hand grown
field you know where we do our
individual observations
um have enjoyed that a lot but that's
about to change so one star at a time
yes I mean there's power to that to
build up intuition of the early Universe
by looking one star at a time yeah and
this is how you can really drill down on
the questions that you have right
because you control what data you get
um otherwise you have the data that you
have right you get what you get and you
don't get upset
I don't like that I'm a little bit
snobby I I really like to formulate my
questions go to the telescope and then
come what may I will try to get it and I
also develop the intuition of where the
data can be relied upon and what it
can't and all the different quirks of
the data and all that kind of stuff yeah
sometimes a lot is lost
in the aggregation of the noisy data
yeah yeah yeah and and that's always the
danger if you have someone else's data
that you just don't really understand
the you know the limitations and
completeness things how certain things
were set up and you know you get out
what you put in so I'm I'm really
particular about that and it certainly
paid off for me that's one of the main
Notions that I try to teach in my
classes and to my my students that
you need to be able to formulate your
quest question really well because
otherwise you're going to get an answer
to a different question but you won't
notice that it had that the goal post
has shifted in the meantime right so
your interpretation can only be as good
as the question if you need to change
your question that's cool do it
but then you know it needs to pair up
with your interpretation again and so
knowing really being in the know about
every step of what happens that relates
to Quality results I think that's why I
have sometimes a little trouble with
with sort of big data and statistical
analysis yes on average that's true I'm
not debating that but I I'm the kind of
person I like to look at the outlier so
not the bulk but you know the special
ones and they just need to be treated in
a different way and there needs to be an
acknowledgment of that different ways
for different things so uh big data can
look at uh divorce rates
and uh perhaps you and I are more
interested in the individual love
stories yes
um so
I don't know if it's possible to say but
what do you think is the big discoveries
that are waiting
uh is it on the different dynamics of
the yield
the common narrative the common story of
how some of these metal poor stars are
formed
is it where are the discoveries in this
field that you think will come
I think the individual discoveries are
actually
we've made most of those certainly
through individual Stars
um finding yet another second generation
size incredibly important for me but
isn't isn't really going to move the
needle
finding 50 of them or 100 of them that
would move the needle but that's in
order or two magnitudes up
and new search techniques and new uh
surveys may enable that but would you
still call that a discovery
right so that's just a scale that's a
scale yes so I think about it more like
literally of the puzzle let's say you
have a thousand piece puzzle and you
know you have 900 pieces in there
if you're a person like me I want to get
to the last ones I'm not gonna leave it
it's like okay I see broadly what this
is going to look like right I'm done now
you know I want to get to the last one
so it was the picture globally going to
change no
are we going to figure out all the
details and how it really works yes
right so really careful getting detailed
into it the the ancient uh the ancient
stars of our universe yeah because I
think that's what many of us scientists
are a real little bit detailed obsessed
but I think that's that's our job too
right to really kind of make it airtight
to really walk away saying I fully
understand this not just broadly
but you know I really know we really
know now and so more and more of that is
going to happen
um and so I think this is probably true
across astronomy these individual
10 Sigma discoveries become less and
less
if they were easy we would have made
them already right which means we have
made many of them but really filling in
the details is is is is is the next sort
of level of Discovery maybe we need to
find a new word for that
um
the hopes and expectations that go along
with the word Discovery are so enormous
we we may not always be able to live up
to that but it doesn't mean that we're
not finding out new things it's just a
different kind of quality because the
questions have shifted you close one
door suddenly that 10 new open doors
that that we want to explore and March
through and that's the you know finding
these last puzzle pieces here and there
that Miri make it airtight so there's a
lot of value a lot of power and Beauty
to the discovery
in the big picture of our universe and
in the details yeah we need both
absolutely